if you and your wife had to cover up a
grisly murder what would you do you've
just accidentally killed your daughter's
gang member boyfriend and now must bury
the body before the police find out
you're guilty and on top of that his
gang suspects you as well what are you
going to do I'm going to break down the
mistakes made what you should do and how
to beat the murder evidence in my home
hero this guy is going to try and
outsmart the most sadistic gang in Japan
tetsuo here is a wannabe crime writer a
family man with a rich wife that's nice
but he's a total loser one day he meets
up with his daughter Reika from
University she enters the restaurant and
sits down but is covering her whole face
and he wonders what's going on and he
asks her to take it off reluctantly she
does and that's when he sees her beaten
up face she tells him she fell and asks
her how many times was it four five
times was it your boyfriend but she gets
annoyed and leaves the restaurant
suspicious he follows her to her
apartment but runs into this blonde hair
to do bag walking by tetsuo he overhears
him talking to his friends about a woman
that he beat up and then he heard the
words Reika he realizes that they're
talking about his kid his daughter
Furious he follows them down the street
and that's when he runs into this
glasses guy he tells tetsuo that he
knows what he's doing and drags him into
this alley beating him up and leaves him
naked taking his naked picture with his
ID and he blackmails him into keeping
his mouth shut and to go home but the
next day though he does the total
opposite and goes to Reagan's apartment
using the spare key that she leaves at
his and his wife's place and then he
snoops around his daughter's house but
that's when he suddenly hears somebody
coming quickly hiding inside of this
closet he holds his breath and sees
reika's boyfriend douchebag Blondie
walking in and he's on the phone with
somebody and he brags to them about how
he loves to beat the [__] out of women
he says he plans to steal all of reika's
family inheritance money and then dump
her and tetsuo then realizes that the
boyfriend is using reika's phone he then
gets told that someone was following him
yesterday and tetsuo can tell by his
reaction that he knows it was tetsuo the
boyfriend starts yelling and breaking
things in the room and that's when
tetsuo accidentally drops his phone on
the floor then the boyfriend hears it he
walks over to the closet but tetsuo
quickly thinks fast and calls his
daughter's phone whispering to the
boyfriend that he will take him down way
to go tetsuo how very uh Liam Neeson of
you outside these men Kubo and kyoichi
wait for Nobu AKA blonde-haired
boyfriend and they wait for him to
return to their car and they whine about
having to babysit the boss's son and
Kubo asks kyoichi to go check on him
meanwhile tetsuo's wife enters the
unlocked apartment to surprise Reika but
discovers something shocking her husband
has just murdered somebody in Cold Blood
with a Japanese rice cooker that's kind
of funny tetsuo panics and confesses to
his wife what he's done but casan
recognizes the corpse and realizes it's
reika's Thug boyfriend Nobu like a
freaking amazing wife she assumes that
he did it for good reasons and she asks
how though cover up this murder listen
up MMA friends in the treacherous land
of raid Shadow Legends a limited
Animated Series has emerged known as
raid called The Arbiter brace yourselves
for this brand new animated series which
is already in full swing by the way now
let's talk about something that we all
love the animation in the call of the
Arbiter is like a well-crafted weapon
hold to Perfection it strikes with
Precision immersing yourself in a world
full of danger and Intrigue the visuals
only
a lure as you bear witness to this
animated Odyssey it will stir Echoes of
familiar Tales adding a thrilling new
Lair to raid's established Universe with
over 12 million views of episodes one to
six so far oh my gosh and thousands of
positive comments people are loving raid
call of the Arbiter but wait there's
more prepare for a slew of Call Of The
Arbiter related features surging through
the ranks of raid Shadow Legends delve
into the depths of champion bios
unearthing the lore behind figures like
Gaelic Ethel kale and elhane all of whom
who take the stage in this Grand
spectacle and fear not beloved fan
favorites like death knight and sill of
the Drake's chill also Gracia presence
so it's fine The Clash of times unfolds
before your very eyes intensifying the
heart pounding excitement survivors
seize this moment paramarks are turning
points in the ever-evolving landscape of
raid this launch brings forth a wealth
of enticing offerings a once in a
lifetime opportunity arises each and
every one of you will have the chance to
claim our attack one of the five new
characters from the show as a legendary
champion for free a gift that
materializes merely by logging into Ray
for seven days from this very moment
until the eve of July 24th but hold on
Brave Souls who have yet to embark on
this perilous Journey check out my link
in the description or heed the call of
my QR code that's mature license before
your very eyes right now claim your free
starter pack Laden with enticing in-game
Loot and let it bolster your chances of
survival so gather your wits and your
allies fellow survivors great Shadow
Legends beckons you to stand tall in the
face of the arbiter's call Unleash Your
Inner Champion or in this Wasteland of
Heroes and monsters your destiny
greatness okay first up that wife is
amazing she's a keeper but besides that
what tetsuo did was completely stupid
but anyways if I was tetsuo what I would
do is probably go have some sexy fun
time with my wife and maybe record it
too what she's my wife it's fine let me
explain what tetsuo did was dumb as hell
he killed a man using a rice cooker not
exactly well thought out I saw the man
that is abusing my daughter I'm
definitely gonna kill him but I'm gonna
take my time first and make sure that I
can get away scot-free and that way my
wife and my daughter will never be
hounded down by his gang thugs by any of
his people here's what we're going to do
step number one I'm going to rely on one
of the most poisonous and funnily enough
very commonly found plants that live
along the roadsides in Japan known as
the red Spider Lily check this out this
thing in high enough doses can induce a
vomiting diarrhea convulsions and even
death doesn't that just sound like a
drug overdose very common among drug
lords thieves and thugs but that's not
even the most cool part these symptoms
can be delayed provided the right dose
is given step two I'm going to begin
tailing the boyfriend for a period of
time and yes I would make sure my
daughter is safe for a few days but
during that time frame I'm going to
figure out his habits and see how often
he goes on long drives and also what are
his eating habits what are the places
that he frequents step three I'm going
to move on to the fun part I'm gonna go
home and convince my wife that we need
to have some sexy fun love time and in
case we die we should maybe record it
and as odd as this sounds and I know
it's weird this is actually going to be
a get out of jail free card and I'm
going to wait until Nightfall I'm gonna
sneak out of the bag with my wife we're
going to go to our car quietly and drive
away out of the neighborhood and
remember we know the boyfriend's
schedule once we find him we're going to
tell the boyfriend and wait for him to
reach and stop in an area that doesn't
have many people from there wifey is
going to get out of the car and put on a
Babushka headscarf sunglasses and a
walking cane she's going to approach
that loser horrible boyfriend and
pretend to need help is he going to help
her probably not but she is going to be
able to distract him long enough in
order for me tetsuo to knock him down
then while he's unconscious we're going
to administer the Red Lily poison mixed
up in a water solution in this syringe
and squirt it right down this kid's
throat did you know weebs a dose of two
milligrams can induce vomiting within
two hours so what we need to do is to
about maybe double or triple that amount
due to the higher dose of poison the
boyfriend would have likely already died
that night his crew would have
investigated the matter and possibly
even the police because he's the son of
a possible drug lord or a Crime Boss and
since he is who he is he probably had
some drugs on him and most likely
overdosed and died from the shock
thinking of what to do next tetsuo
realizes that they are likely up against
a criminal organization and his
daughter's boyfriend was somehow
involved with him he tries to think of
the next steps but his wife goes full on
evil and suggests that they bury the
body and then tetsuo has an idea he
tells her to go get these six items
because it's going to help them get away
with murder outside of the apartment
kyoichi tries to listen in and thinks
that blonde guy is talking with the
woman that he saw enter earlier not
realizing that she is tetsuo's wife but
suddenly he gets alerted on the radio by
Kubo that Reika is returning back to her
apartment kuoichi plays it cool as Reika
passes him by entering her apartment she
discovers her family in her place and
tetsuo nervously says that they were
planning to surprise her here but ran
into her boyfriend who beat him up but
he also mentions that the boyfriend
yelled he was going to kill Reika here
as well and reik confesses that even
though her Bae is a bad boy she thought
she could change him classic problem
tetsuo's wife tells Reika that she
should stay at their place for a little
while meanwhile though tetsuo is
cleaning up the apartment because he's
such a nice Dad wink wink and he's going
to meet them back at the house outside
kyoichi continues to monitor the place
and he notices the woman Enrique Leaf
but his man Nobu hasn't left yet and
it's rather strange so he goes inside to
check it out entering the room he sees
nobody there but here's something coming
from the bathroom approaching it slowly
he opens the door and sees this lady
cleaning the cleaning lady introduces
herself as Suzuki and says the owner of
this apartment hired her and kyoichi
recovers quickly and mentions that his
friend left his phone here somewhere so
he's going to look for it and he calls
it tetsuo I mean Suzuki is sweating
buckets but koichi ends up not being
able to hear the phone ring saying it
must be disconnected voicing kyoichi to
leave without having any answers he
returns to Kubo in the car and tells him
that Nobu has disappeared Kubo doesn't
think much of it but orders kyoichi to
follow the daughter Reika for now just
in case and he goes to tell their boss
that they've just lost his son that's
gonna turn out well meanwhile tetsuo
catches his breath inside of the
apartment just as his wife arrives back
with his shopping list he tells her that
he'll cook Nobu by turning the bathtub
into a pot cooking nobu's fleshy body
like a steak this will make the water
from the body evaporate making him
smaller and easier to transport he
thanks his wife and tells her to go home
and wait for him later tetsuo boils the
body and transport the now shrunken
remains in this suitcase and he lugs it
back home bones and flesh which on
average usually weigh around 20
kilograms back at his house he tries to
figure out his next move he could dry
the bones out but the remaining flesh
will begin to rot in a few days which
will then be a big problem the next day
Casa notices a suspicious car parked
outside that she's never seen before and
tedswell realizes that it was also there
when he arrived back home last night and
it saw him carrying that suitcase
deciding to play it safe they make short
not to move nobu's corpse for now but
tetzel then has another idea he grabs an
empty suitcase and stuffs it with
clothes getting inside of his car he
drives to a warehouse store to get some
supplies but when he comes back to his
car he discovers that his trap worked
somebody opened his trunk and has been
through his suitcase tetsuo now knows
that he's being followed but he wasn't
taken which makes him realize they don't
think he's connected yet this means that
they're just following him observing him
he rushes back home and tells his wife
that they need to get rid of the body
right here in this house right now by
using these ingredients that will help
them cover up the murder he shows her
composite accelerator microbes potting
mix for gardening and tells her that the
compost accelerator placed on top of the
Flesh and buried in moist dirt start the
decomposition process sooner and by
using a high amount of accelerator it
will get rid of the rest of Nobu body
within day or so he thinks Reika walks
in and catches them and asks what
they're up to but she doesn't know that
the body is inside of the pot covered in
dirt cosin quickly says that they're
starting a garden kitchen and Reika gets
excited but wonders why they're doing it
in a pot so she offers to help them but
suggest that they do that outside they
agree and say great idea and she leaves
and while all of this is going on
outside they're being watched by koichi
and his men he then sees tetsuo's family
step out and tells one of his men to go
and distract them while he looks inside
for Clues and this Shady looking man
then goes up to tetsuo and tells him
that he's conducting surveys around town
and asks him a bunch of questions but
tetsuo can tell that he has some major
glasses guy energy and quickly chases
him away but that's when he realizes
that if there are people following him
then that must mean somebody's inside of
their house he rushes in and quickly
goes into the room with a plant pot but
sees it safe and sound and has no idea
that somebody is watching him from
inside of the closet staying hidden
kyoichi here wonders why tetsuo rushed
into this room of all places anyway
radios his men that he's going to sneak
out since he didn't find anything later
Casa discovers a listening device in
their house and these two secretly
discuss their new plans they make up a
fake conversation for the microphone
they discuss where reiko's boyfriend
went to and revealed that she has had a
stalker following her over the last few
months and wonder if the stalker had
anything to do with the boyfriend's
disappearance tetsuo pretends to
discover the microphone again and
announce that they're going to call the
police overhearing their conversation
kyoichi and his men drive off and tetsuo
and his family wait for the plant to rot
away their evidence but they realize
that they're running out of time that
was way too close if I was them I'm
gonna speed up this process to give
everybody you said we're gonna do it let
a composite accelerator that basically
releases nitrogen to the bacteria and
fungi within the compost soil putting a
little bit of that in there is going to
speed up the breakdown process also
buying a standard pot plant that's heavy
as hell and not mobile is kind of dumb I
would switch out the heavy ceramic pot
with something lighter a plastic dose
can be found commonly anywhere now it's
lighter since we don't really know how
much time we have exactly before nobu's
bodies now mush I'm going to put the
potted plant outside on our balcony
during the day and then place it inside
of our bathroom and turn on the shower
and between the sunlight outside and the
moisture inside of the bathroom it's
going to speed up the decomposing
process because look the police and the
gangs in Japan have a love-hate
relationship which means it's unlikely
that anybody who suspects us is going to
just enter our home without knowing for
sure that we are guilty and the last
thing that I want to do is upset the
delicate balance between the gangs and
the police by leaving the pot inside of
our for now safe house the bad guys are
not going to be able to do much or the
police for that matter all they're going
to say is that we're putting the pot
outside and then we're taking it back
inside at night later tattoo and his
family try to move the plant pot but
it's too heavy so tetsuo prepares a
series of questions to his wife he tells
her to memorize all of them in case they
get caught in the future the next day
tetsuo goes back to reika's apartment to
do a little bit more extra cleaning wink
wink but he discovers a newspaper of a
father being arrested for murder while
kyoichi secretly Tails him outside the
updates kobu on the phone and tells
tetsu and his family made up the story
about the stalker he knows they are
hiding something he asks to interrogate
both of them but kobu denies his request
saying that they shouldn't act until
they know the full story however the
kyoichi doesn't listen and prepares to
go ahead with a plan an hour later
kiroichi raids tetsuo and his family
kidnapping tetsuo and holds his wife
hostage kyoichi tries to make them
confess to making up the stalker story
but tetsuo thinks fast telling him that
Reika was in trouble a few months ago
and because of this him and his wife
hired a private investigator to
investigate and his name was Suzuki and
suddenly kyoichi realizes that the
person he met at reika's apartment from
before was the detective in Disguise
still not satisfied though kyoichi's man
put tetsuo through a mock execution to
try and find out more information about
Nobu and tetsuo begs them to check his
phone finding the private detective's
email on there kyoichi thinks it's
suspicious but tetsuo says they don't
contact through the phone for privacy
reasons and they delete all their emails
for this very reason meaning there's no
way to prove if any of this is true in
kyohich gets mad and badly injures
tetsuo saying he'll confirm the story
with his wife he calls her up but she
ends up saying this same thing
confirming tetsuo's story his wife then
improvises and pretends to cry and freak
out about not wanting to die and this
annoys the man holding her down they
tell kyoichi that they're leaving the
house and calling off the search kyoichi
begs them to stay but they don't listen
annoying him his boss Kubo also finds
out what he's doing and gives him [__]
for not listening to orders and his
position gets replaced by another member
named Takara everyone leaves and tetsuo
and kyoichi remain hentai's tetsuo but
declares that he will kill him now
anyways and frame him in order to prove
he was right he takes out his knife and
is about to murder him when tetsuo yells
out that he's gotten extra information
from his Pi about Nobu and it's
something that kyoichi will want tetsuo
tries to calm him down and says that
they can work together to find Nobu
somehow convincing the man to work
together but qhichi also warned that
they must find Nobu by Friday or he will
kill him anyways later his wife picks
him up and thinks that they are now in
the clear but Teto decides to keep her
in the dark about what developments have
just happened while he thinks about his
next move option one he hides his crimes
and collects evidence against the bad
guys and report them or option 2 frame
someone else for nobu's murder but what
is tetsuo do he goes with option three
fake that Nobu is still alive Justin
Reika comes in and he asks her for a
picture of her boyfriend he then tells
his wife that he's going to work but
instead he goes to buy himself a hat to
cover his bandage and then goes to meet
kyoichi there koichi tells tetsuo that
his gang knows he followed to Nobu
before he went missing and tetsuo tells
it that Nobu was beating his daughter so
he followed him but eventually lost him
and they then decide to try and retrace
Nobu steps by hitting up all the spots
that he went to that day before he
disappeared starting with this Shady
karaoke bar in there they meet this
woman who claims to be nobu's girlfriend
named hibiki she reveals that Nobu
cheated on her with many women but he
told her that he was in love with only
her so she stayed but she also mentions
that he was dating a girl named Reika at
the time but she was just a job for him
to steal her money according to Nobu He
also mentioned that Reika was not a city
girl and was boring and a needy virgin
in bed that was the last straw for
tetsuo and he excuses himself to the
bathroom where he tries to calm himself
down heading back to the bar he notices
that kyoichi has left but he continues
to talk with hibiki she tells him that
she knows he's reika's dad because
nobu's boss came in here yesterday and
showed everyone here his picture and
this makes him realize that everybody
now knows about his family meanwhile
though kyoichi listens through tetsuo's
phone from another room he hears hibiki
asks tetzel why he's looking for Nobu
but the audio gets muffled and he can't
hear what he says back in the room
tetsuo purposely drops his phone deeper
into his bag and Whispers to hibiki if
Nobu ever told her anything else since
it seemed like she wanted to tell him
something before kyuichi left he then
makes up a line warns her that it's
possible someone within the gang tried
to have Nobu killed because of what he
might know desperate she then reveals
that he was trying to win her back a
Nobu led her in on a huge secret six
months ago his gang was supposed to rob
a truck full of money but the day before
Nobu robbed it all alone and he didn't
tell his gang and he kept all the money
for himself and no one knows about this
hibiki then tells him about nobu's
Secret online account that he had and
she thinks his crime gang doesn't know
about this account either tetsu can use
this he can use this account to
establish nobu's betrayal or fabricate
evidence that Nobu is still alive
yes tetsuo tries to hide his smile
because he just found his Ace in the
Hole with the Nobu secret account he'll
be able to fake evidence that Noble is
still alive and suddenly this waiter
shows up and builds tetsuo for 10
million yen but Tesla says that he
doesn't have enough and neither does
kyoichi so they could tie it up and this
guy comes in and gets annoyed at kyoichi
for hanging out with a suspect and tells
him that their funny business has now
cost them and he gives these two three
options for paying him back one pay the
10 million two borrow money from the
higher-ups or three do a job for them
that pays 10 million and by the way the
job is tonight with no choice they
accept the Shady job and are forced into
the mountains on a wild goose chase
tetsuo nervously asks yoichi if this was
part of the plan they oversee a
transaction between two gangs and they
must steal their package from them or
die if they refuse waiting in the car
koichi sudden reveals that he knows for
a fact that tetsuo killed Nobu and this
is why he agreed to team up with him
shocking tetsuo because this guy just
never gives up but then they get alerted
that it's go time and they prepare to
steal the package but that's when shots
start firing bullets fly through the car
piercing through kyoichi the car quickly
catches on fire just as these large
trucks show up from kuichi's gang okay
this is really bad this is insane the
fact is for a badass capable of murder
tattoo was acting way too stupid if we
notice check this out tetzel's wife
acted way too calmly when she discovered
the dead body that means that either
she's a secret professional serial
killer like a Mr Mrs Smith kind of
scenario or she's our ride or die boo
either way not to telling her about what
was going on was seriously stupid since
it's clear that she can handle it I mean
she just watched the guy die now while
we don't know what kind of gang these
people are in it's likely that they're
from a smaller gang and they don't
exactly look the most organized but you
can kind of tell from based on how they
held down tetsuo's wife the men left the
job shortly thereafter unlike the Yakuza
these men don't seem as capable as the
Yakuza which is something that we can
use but on second thought I mean not
telling my wife is actually kind of a
good thing because kyoichi right now is
shot har is about to blow up and also we
know of the people in this gang don't
exactly have a lot of resources which
means it could kill kyoichi right now
and leave his body here in the car
problem solved all we have to do is
escape down that Cliff right there the
car exploding means his body's not
exactly going to be great for an autopsy
which would make it harder for the
police coroner to identify upon
examination and all the while the
criminals will not know whose body it is
and we can use that period of time to
alert our family and get the hell out of
Dodge Japan not only has Yakuza separate
to this former members of violence
groups now when we get back to our
family we're going to leave town but
also I'm gonna find a way to reach out
to as many of these other organizations
and tell them that kyoichi's gang
Leader's son is dead and that their
organization right now is weak they'll
take that opportunity and any sensible
crime Lord will investigate a little bit
and if it's true they might just hop on
a great situation and take advantage of
the smaller organization's weakness and
absorb the group and their territory
creating a distraction tetsuo carries
kyoichi down the hill why would you do
that just let him die anyways he's able
to take him out escape the madness but
that's when they run into one of these
guys he points his gun at them and
prepares to fire but then they get saved
by kyoichi's men Kubo shows up and helps
take the bullet of kyoichi telling him
that if he keeps not listening to orders
he's gonna be in deep [__] they also add
to tetzel's Blackmail list and force him
to admit he killed this guy and they
keep the video just in case and they let
him go home later he finally admits to
his wife that they're still in deep [__]
he tells her that nobu's gang is still
monitoring them and they have three days
left to find Nobu or else everybody here
is going to die and then he reveals the
most crazy plan yet he tells his wife
that they're going to plant fake
evidence showing that Nobu is still
alive with an online video forgive my
skepticism let's see what happens tetso
remembers an old actor friend of his
that looks like Nobu and somebody that
nobody knows about he tells his wife to
team up with the actor to film the fake
video while he tries to break into
nobu's Secret online account and they
get ready for their grand plan the next
day Carson meets up with her friend she
lies to him about why they are shooting
this strange film and makes the actor
put on this wig saying they'll only
shoot him from behind meanwhile tetsuo
tries to get into nobu's Secret online
account but there's a path's word [__]
he tries to reset it but the new login
has been sent to nobu's phone and with
nobu's current phone being destroyed
Tesla then has an idea he hits up hibiki
finding out that she has one of nobu's
old phones and it is synced with his
account and they secretly meet up and
tetso gets a hold of the old phone he
goes into focusing on resetting nobu's
online password account but that's when
it hits him with a security question
that stops him dead what is the name of
his pet he checks in with hibiki and his
daughter in a subtle way and no one
thinks that he has any pets and now he's
hit a dead end but he decides to
confront the gang member that has been
following him and asks him if he can
give him a ride he's falling all over
the place he might as well be useful in
the car tetsuo gets chatty with the
driver and asks about his life no boost
life and if it's common for gang members
to have pets but the dumb driver
confirms that it's impossible for them
to have pets since they move around a
lot tetsuo then realizes that the
security question must be about no boost
childhood pet heading into town he heads
over to a bar that Nobu frequented and
prepares to ask around about Nobu but
that's when he notices this strange
creepy already sitting there dude and
guess what he's wearing glasses moving
on this glasses guy then starts talking
for no reason annoying the crap out of
tetsuo and he talks about his life and
his family but tetsuo finds out that
this stranger has a child about the same
age as his daughter and that they used
to own a pet named cap that's what tries
to end this out of nowhere conversation
but that's when the man starts going
full psycho he asks tetsuo straight to
his face what would he do if somebody
killed his family and he doesn't even
wait for tetsuo replies and says that
Vengeance must be taken upon anybody who
messes with a Man's family he then
introduces himself as yoshiatsu tetsuo
now freaked out gives him a fake name
the man leaves the bar he shakes off the
weirdness and gets back to his main
mission he takes out a picture of Nobu
that Reika gave him and asks this
bartender if he knows anything about it
but that's when the bar tender reveals
that glasses guy who just left was
nobu's daddy tetzel is shocked and runs
out to look for him but realizes that
the man's gone tetsuo rushes home and
tells his wife who he just met and
realizes that he mentioned that they had
a pet named cap putting the name into
the computer they managed to gain access
to nobu's online account and with 24
hours left until tetsuo dies with their
life on the line tetsuo tells his wife
that he bought a tablet with all of
nobu's information on it including the
fake video online his login passwords
and nobu's Bones using this package full
of stuff they'll be able to frame
anybody for nobu's murder in the worst
case scenario the next day the gang
leader and father of Nobu yoshiatsu
declares that if they don't find his son
to leave Japan and the Gang leaving them
without a leader nervous kobu tells him
that without him the organization will
likely crumble but yoshiatsu says that
without his son he is nothing and just
then they get a call with some new
information and it's good news to Kubo
elsewhere Tessa gets found by kyoichi
and he confronts him about what he said
to hibiki in the karaoke bar sent he
couldn't hear him Tesla makes something
up and tells him that his phone slipped
into his bag and kyochi tells him that
he knows the true story tetso didn't
hire a pi only a cleaning service and
that that cleaning service person saw
Nobu leave the apartment and told tetsuo
where Nobu was and that's when tetsuo
killed him tetzel told him that he's
crazy and he has no evidence but kyoichi
smiles and says that he doesn't need
evidence as Logan's nobu's father
believes the story tetsuo is a walking
dead man with no backup moves left Tesla
tries to remain calm but that's when
they get a call from kyoichi's gang
telling him that they found a Nobu they
find an online video of someone who
looks just like Nobu and it's a little
weird they can't see his face and in the
comments of the video somebody was
claiming that they are the real Nobu the
gang is also verified that the
mysterious Comet came from nobu's
private account they update to Nobu and
kyoichi that they are verifying the
video but they ordered kyoichi to go to
meet up with this new boss man named
Takara and to take tetsuo with him they
go to meet the mysterious man but both
of them don't realized this man is going
to ruin their lives later they arrive at
this van and see the gang members
analyzing the video they reveal that it
was uploaded from an anonymous source
which was shot in low quality making it
hard to identify anything they get
annoyed that hibiki didn't tell them
about nobu's online social media account
and says that they should mess her up
next time they see her to keep her in
line they have no idea that tetsu is
hiding an extra phone under his hat
already on a call with his wife who's
listening in just in case they need to
go to plan B to Target the one man who
is their current biggest threat here
kyoichi tetsuo makes small talk with
everybody and figures out their laptops
reset every time they turn it on and qat
gets annoyed that his gang is revealing
information and is about to throw hands
when takada comes in and tells everybody
that he's 70 sure that the online video
of Nobu is a fake they think the man in
the video doesn't walk like Nobu but
takita tells them to confirm for sure
making tetsuo Shake in fear about what's
to come alright look for a bunch of
suburban killers teddo and his wife
really did everything wrong here I would
have dressed up fake Nobu like a
Japanese layered dish let me explain the
way people walk is known as their gate
okay each person's gate is unique
depending on their weight spinal
alignment posture yada yada the point is
why change just the hair you gotta
change the whole person he has to embody
Nobu because the people who know him
best might be able to pick up on cues
that are not Nobu for example why wear
restrictive clothing like skinny jeans
that restricts free movement in the
areas of the hips and knees whereas if
you wear baggy clothing that's gonna
hide more of the subtleties of a gate
and sure they might have picked up on
why the heck would Noble dress like this
but it does eliminate one factor that
they can use to figure out if this Nobu
is real or not kyoichi then drags tetsuo
out to show him something getting in the
car he tells him to make sure that his
family's out of the house when they get
there and he has no idea that teto's
wife is already listening in on the
whole thing arriving kyoichi also tells
tetso the last time he was here he
thought that plant pot was rather
suspicious and he tells him to dump it
Ted so nervously pours out the dirt
praying to the good Lord that that flesh
has already finished rotting and it has
but he notices a single strand of nobu's
blonde hair and kyoichi starts to notice
something in the dirt but that's just
when tetzal's wife shows up and drags
them back in the house for drinks oh
that was close with this guard to
lowered kyoichi tells them that he has
planted listening devices in the house
and that he's a hunter then the wife
gets really mad but he says if she tries
anything he is already blackmailed
tetsuo and that's when kyoichi suddenly
gets a stomach ache and runs into the
bathroom and that's when tetsuo realizes
that his wife has put laxatives in his
drink oh This Woman's amazing using this
opportunity he quickly opens up
kyoichi's laptop and opens up his email
but its password locked [__] but that's
when his stomach suddenly starts feeling
weird and he discovers that his wife put
laxatives in both their drinks in order
to make sure that kyochi doesn't get
suspicious he quickly tells his wife
that he will install a keylogger
software on his laptop that will track
what password kyoichi uses to get into
his email later and through this they
will be able to find out his address
since they'll both need his password and
work ID number to Access his work email
quickly installing software he then
rushes to go but is forced to do it
outside then Reika comes home and has an
awkward encounter talking about her
boyfriend choichi then comes out and
mentions that he knows about her missing
boyfriend and he takes his laptop back
into the bathroom Reika gets mad at her
family that this stranger told her about
Nobu and not them but they tell her a
fake story that they were asking him for
his advice on a situation since he is
tetsuo's work client and a known
womanizer which means he knows how women
think because that clearly makes sense
kyoichi then comes out all finished and
drags tetso out to go somewhere else
meanwhile Carson rushes to her laptop
using the key logger they quickly
install and they are able to figure out
kyochi's email password and login seeing
that kyoji just received an email about
tetsuo and his family the email States
they'll know if the online video of Nobu
is fake within 24 hours that if it is
yoshiatsu will leave the company forever
she also sees instructions for kyoichi
to keep watch on tetsuo until then and
then to frame him for the murder if they
get no answers meanwhile Reika is about
to go out but that's when she notices a
note and her shoe left by kyoichi
telling her that her parents are hiding
something and that he has secrets that
he can tell or if they want to meet he
also leaves his email and she decides to
contact him all right oh we're in big
trouble here look Reiki here has just
been targeted by sick suspicious
douchebag and if I was her I would use
the power of networking known as an
online women's group let me explain
Reika is a college woman who's just told
that a person she's about to contact is
a known womanizer and this means that
despite all the smarts people can try
and get at school some people will just
never be that bright which means I'm
getting some major Sakura vibes from her
but if I was Reika before meeting this
man I would first pose a question and
then I would ask maybe in Reddit and see
how dumb my thinking really is because
the man who just left was like 20 000
times our age and then we have to
consider the feeling what it must be
like to be well attracted because
according to Cora and the ask women of
Reddit which is a really nice subreddit
by the way when we get hit on 75 and a
quarter times on average per day at
least that's what it seems like
according to the comments anyways at
this point with the way that we look and
the situation where and it's clear that
this man is obsessed with us which is
why I would work on figuring out how to
disengage with this stalker stalkers on
average are either unemployed or I have
a job that allows them to take off for
their stalking and this means that he
could strike again at any time and the
first thing we shouldn't do is to
respond to stalker's calls for attention
don't do that but what I would do is
start to gather evidence on him and I'm
also going to keep this letter and I
would likely tell everybody about this
man hell I would even post it on
Instagram Facebook and even LinkedIn
everywhere that way people will be
paying attention if we happen to go
missing seeing the horrible email Kasen
forwards it to tetsu and warns him to
find kyoji's address now she also finds
kyoichi's mother's email and takes out
nobu's bones and the evidence with her
and plans to frame her arriving at qe's
Mother's house chance of feeling kind of
bad about this and decides to abort
Mission she gets heading back and she
gets updated from the key logging
software from kyoichi's device that an
email is being sent and she finds out
that kyoichi is trying to meet up with
her daughter for some reason forcing her
to come up with a plan on the spot
meanwhile kyoichi takes tetsu out to
reika's apartment he starts searching
around and calls someone on the phone he
then handcuffs tetsuo and tells him that
he's leaving for a bit but he is also
tracking tetsuo on his phone in case he
tries anything funny now alone tetsuo
quickly takes out his key logging
software and finds out that kyoichi has
been texting his daughter and is on his
way to meet her he also finds out from
his email that somebody from kyot's gang
is coming to deliver a package to
reika's apartment he calls his wife and
tells her to come meet him quick along
with a bag full of evidence and also to
bring a GPS tetso slips out of the
handcuffs right as his wife arrives and
he places a GPS tracker inside of this
empty envelope logging into kyoti's
email and pretending to be kyoichi he
tells the Run arriving soon that if he
can also deliver an envelope inside
reika's mailbox and to deliver that to
his apartment using the GPS they'll be
able to find out where qhichi lives and
tetsuo deletes all traces of this email
he then runs down in places the envelope
with the GPS tracker inside of the
mailbox and they wait minutes later
I just made it the runner arrives to
deliver tetsuo's package and he takes
the package that he thinks kyoichi left
for him waiting for the runner to leave
tetsu and his wife then look inside of
the package and kyoichi has just
received and discovers an ALS flashlight
inside and realizes that kyoichi plans
to use this to find any secret blood
stains in reika's apartment on the clock
he quickly tells his wife to go stop a
Reika from eating kyoichi while he
tracks down kyoichi's apartment and he
leaves his phone here to not be tracked
and the two split up knowing that he
must get back here in time before
kyoichi comes back cosen quickly tracks
break it down and pretends to
accidentally bump into her and she
starts getting all emotional and forces
Reika to hang out with her instead
meanwhile though tracking the GPS tetsuo
soon arrives at kyoichi's apartment and
sees which mailbox therunner places his
oversized envelope through this he finds
out kirich's apartment number and heads
straight there and then he gets an
update that Casa has stopped Reika from
meeting kyoichi reaching the apartment
he finds out that qut has lock proofed
his door so good that the lock is
blurred on screen that's in fun facts my
weebs did you know it's illegal to show
luck picking even in anime I know so
weird but then Ted's will realizes that
he can't get in he tries to access his
room from the roof but also can't get in
forcing him to come up with a new plan
he rushes to this store and buys a
regular black light that cannot detect
the blood stains and then he heads back
to reika's apartment and leaves his
envelope inside of reika's mailbox
kyochi will think that it's for him
kyoji also arrives just a few minutes
later and goes to pick up the envelope
that he thinks the runner left for him
he takes out the flashlight in the
apartment and sees that tetso is still
chained up and he begins using it to see
if he can find any of nobu's blood
stains here and he has no idea that he's
not using the same light that the runner
left him and sure enough he doesn't find
anything but he senses something is off
and he calls the runner to complain but
he tells kyoichi that he's using the
best brand of flashlight he also tells
him that he left a package at his
apartment like he asked hearing this
kyochi gets confused but the runner
tells him that kyochi sent him an email
about 30 minutes ago suspicious kyoji
looks at tetsuo but real realizes that
according to the GPS on his phone
tatsuell never left reika's apartment he
then decides to restart his laptop
erasing all the data on his account for
that day along with the email to the
runner tetsuo quickly mentions that he
thinks Takara might be trying to frame
him instead because how could he do
anything he's been inside the apartment
the whole time but then he has a
realization and says that it might be
possible that taka had put something in
koichi's apartment now a little nervous
kyoichi then decides to go back to his
place and check it out and takes tetsuo
with him there kyochi finds no envelope
in his mailbox and gets even more
confused heading inside of his apartment
tetsuo clocks kyoichi's safe and sees
that he has a little bit of extra cash
there and tenzo then reveals two QE that
he wants to take down Takara for putting
his family through all of this hell and
asks yoichi that they should work
together on taking Takata down before he
takes them down but Koji still thinks
he's suspicious as hell and says that by
tomorrow either way one of them will be
dead Ted's old then tries something so
freaking stupid it's not gonna work he
tries to sweet talk to kyoichi and make
him relatable telling him about how both
their family died when they were young
and His holy [__] his trick worked qut
Lloyd his guard cannot believe it he
then decides to make dinner for them and
tetzel secretly unlocks his balcony door
when he's not looking of course after
they get called to go meet with
kyoichi's gang reaching there kyoichi
gets in trouble for not following orders
again and Takara tells them both that
the online video of Nobu is officially
fake they now declare that Nobu is
officially kidnapped or dead the smoke
in the room causes tetso to cough and
excuses himself to the bathroom and
there he signals his wife Kasen to head
over to kirichi's place now knowing the
layout thanks to tetsuo she comes
stocked with all the toys and manages to
climb over climb down and sneak into
kyoichi's place through his balcony what
the frick I'm impressed using the ALS
light they stole from the envelope
earlier she uses it to see kyoichi's
fingerprint on the lock and with a
little bit of luck she opens it and
places nobu's bones right in the back of
cure she's safe she then sends an
anonymous email to Takara revealing to
him that Nobu is the one responsible for
the armed robbery six months ago and
that kyoichi was his partner meanwhile
tetzel heads back from the bathroom it
quickly Whispers to kyoichi no one here
can be trusted Justin takite comes in
and says that he wants to speak to
tetsuo outside there he tells tetsuo
what he secretly already knows about
nobu's involvement with the armed
robbery and his connection to kyoichi
because they just received an email
about all of this he then asks tetsuo to
tell him everything that he's found out
about kyoichi and tetsuo tells him that
kyoji never liked Nobu getting
suspicious Takara then announces to
everyone that they must head to
kyoichi's place immediately because
something is going on kyoichi now thinks
that tetsu is playing him and tries to
hit him but gets stopped by his men and
everybody heads on over arriving at the
apartment takitas men hold kyoichi down
and they go through his place and find
the hidden cash inside of his safe
scanning it they quickly realize that
this isn't the money from the armed
robbery we find a strange package at the
back of the safe kyoichi doesn't know
what it is and swears that he's never
seen it before and he starts panicking
opening the bank they discover a tablet
logged into nobu's online account to the
fake video and even human bones and they
all realize that it's no no boost and
that means kyochi must be the killer
gosh that's awesome Ken realizes that
that's all must have set him up and
tells his man that tattoo must have
broke it into his lockproof apartment
and puts nobu's bones in his safe and
sent the faked emails and must be
working with Takeda cause that sounds
totally believable everybody looks at
him like he's an idiot and Kubo tells
koichi that while some facts don't make
sense either he is so useless that some
idiot this guy tetsuo managed to frame
him or he's in fact so smart that he is
actually a traitor and Kubo says that
because he has so much respect for
kyoichi he doesn't want to insult his
intelligence and thinks that he has to
be the killer sealing kyoichi's fate
he's got a big problem now because he's
so freaking squeaky clean that they
don't think he's capable of anything
that's really really bad things might
turn against him and then he'll be
looking the worst out of all of them yes
tetsu is brilliant because he pulled all
of this off but like I said he's so
squeaky clean let me explain there's
this crazy law known as the law of
economy everybody thinks that tetsuo is
too innocent not capable of much so what
do they do they logically went with the
simplest explanation the thing that had
the least amount of assumption which is
smartypants kyoichi was more likely
capable of committing this murder and
this crime and doing all this crazy
stuff then tetsuo but they're not
looking at it from a bird's eye view but
what if say takita decides to take a
step back and look at things differently
kyoichi a loyal longtime gang member
antakada a new entity who is a devoted
father he loves his family and he will
do anything to save them what I would do
I would leave town straight away because
kyuchi has now been found already guilty
and really the only person's opinion
matters here is the big boss and unlike
everybody here he is a parent and one
who we know will do anything for their
child and just like how he became
unhinged when he was forced to save his
child from abuse the same thing is
probably going to happen to the big boss
man Kubo feels sorry for kyoichi and
tells his man to bring him back to their
boss leader in a body bag as the sun
comes up Teto gets a lot off the hook
and heads home he tags his wife that
he'll be back later and he stops by
reika's apartment to catch his breath
and he passes out an exhaustion
meanwhile back at qh's apartment he
refuses to die and breaks free and
quickly escapes his men he tries to
trick them and heads to the roof
sneaking back down into his apartment
through this shaft that's when he sees
ladder marks on his balcony and notices
that his balcony was unlocked this whole
time it's strange and he quickly heads
out and goes on the run and then he
finally puts the clues together and
realizes that tetsuo are somebody that
knows him must have snuck into his place
changing disguises he calls the boss
leader and tells him that the real
killer is tetsuo and if he gives him a
chance he'll explain everything to him
meanwhile Reika at home tells her mother
that she thinks she recognized the
client that tetsu had over earlier she
says that the day Nobu went missing she
thinks she saw him hanging outside of
her apartment realizing this she thinks
her father's client is stalking her
later back at reika's apartment tetsuo
wakes up from his nap and sees somebody
trying to enter and he quickly hides and
he sees who comes in it's yoshiatsu he's
carrying an ALS flashlight and finds
blood right in front of where tetsuo is
hiding he breaks down crying but sees
Blood on the closet door before he can
open it tetsuo comes out he's given up
and wants to end this suffering for
everybody he apologizes to yoshiatsu and
says he'll call the police but this
psycho smiles and says oh that won't be
necessary he's going to do the nastiest
things to his family first he's gonna
put fish hooks in tetsuo's eyes and
force him to watch as him and his gang
do things after that they'll skin them
alive crucify them burned them and then
cut off their hands feet and Hammer
Nails all over their body and then slice
open their stomach so all of their guts
falls out and then Place their cut off
heads in front of tetsuo tetsuo begs him
to just kill him but he doesn't listen
yoshiatsu takes out his phone but that's
when he loses it and attacks him the two
go at it meanwhile outside yoshiatsu's
bodyguard waits for him but sees the
police roll up back inside the two
fathers though I guess technically now
only one is a father fight but then
yoshiatsu gets even more sad and
realizes that nothing he does will bring
his son back he then does this nastiness
shocking tetsuo and suddenly there's a
knock on the door it's the police
they've come because of a noise complete
tezo takes advantage of yoshiatsu and
chokes him out all the while as he makes
up some BS lie to the place about why he
can't come to the door the police then
let him off with a warning and leave not
realizing the blood running to the door
and yoshiatsu dies in tetsuo's arm a few
minutes later yoshiatsu's driver comes
in to look for him but can't find him he
caused Takara and tells him that he's
lost the Crime Boss butagada says that
after all the Heartbreak he's
experienced it's likely that he left by
himself since he was planning to leave
the gang anyways and tells him to report
back and forget about it since there's
no point and his son robbed them anyways
so staying hidden in the bathroom with
yoshiatsu's corpse tetsuo finally
breathes aside relief and finally free
Teto gets to work and does what he does
best a few months later Japan suddenly
gets news that it will experience the
biggest typhoon in history and will
likely destroy much of the soil and dirt
around the city and tetsuo thinks of
where he buried his final victim and
what does he do he maintains the biggest
poker face Japan has ever seen well he
figures out how to keep his position but
what do you think about the video don't
forget to like subscribe and leave a
comment down below and as always don't
forget to check out our how to be
playlist